Hello freaky bitches.
I feel like if you created a situation where Iran saw that there was much more
to be gained from joining the Economic Community and playing ball in accordance
with its laws is then in getting weapons of mass destruction.
They're all scared that those chicks are going to find out they don't have to
wear burkas in America.
Votes cover your cover,
your come over on boats and the seek out black dick like a magnet,
like a magnet to steal filings.
Perhaps they're tired of being suppressed.
They want a torque on some dude in a club,
maybe no crazy funky religious outfit on and they can escape.
You know why?
Because no one knows the fuck they look like they could just blend right in.
Good luck in your passport photo when it's looking through a fucking lit of a
garbage can like Oscar the grouch and that's what you're,
that's what you're fucking passport.
It looks like he's here eyeballs.
I mean they have to take their shit out for their basketball,
right?
Don't they are they are loud too.
It's like stealing their soul or something.
Right?
Well,
I,
the minute that a lot of Saudi women goes to places like London and quite guess
what comes off immediately their head dress,
the whole burden of thing and then go shopping and they dress sexy outfits and
they're just like,
yeah cause Russian man.
It's just amazing that you're,
you've got countries that in 2015 still make women dressed like they're in star
wars.
This is not the reason for it.
Another reason for it.
There was not there very logical reason for it.
Logical.
Well I'm just saying if you're,
if you're,
if you're really,
if you're a,
if you're a living,
I'm just saying if you're a religious man and if you are trying to create a
productive society,
the logic went,
if you have women walking around looking all sexy and naked,
which was a lot of the Middle East,
well if you have that,
what happens is we're thinking about fucking and not producing.
Yeah.
So you've got it covers your chicks up jam and she want to get any work done.
That's not true though.
I come to America producers like a mother fucker about that.
How he got hot freaks over the hill.
It's so true.
Freedom.
Is that what you really Prince Princess Leia.
Is that a real body?
Yeah.
Damn Shit.
A banging body as she did those real to those pre pre suck and Tuck.
God bless her.
You know,
she didn't have no light Po couldn't look more board.
Um,
she was beautiful at the time.
Very exotic.
I must say.
Bruns Leo,
what does steel bro I made out with her brother.
I remember that Shit.
I love it.
She kissed her brother and Ellipsis tick.
Is that true?
It had to.
He didn't know that it was his sister.
That's rude.
You sister comes along and gives you a real kiss since he got some Univision
cheesy,
even bother telling you that she's,
did she know at the time she knows she was?
No,
no one knew.
I don't know if
you've experienced this yet,
but for me,
you know,
I've hunted a lot and so I almost like to punish myself and some,
I like it to be hard.
I like to be a challenge.
So I will actually create it to be,
I just this hunt in New Zealand where I was hunting these,
these fallow deer and at any given time for the first few days I could have shot
a deer.
Well if hunt a lot of people don't realize as hunters,
it's not always the goal to just go shoot something.
It's part of the experience.
And so for me,
I just kept passing up animals because the experience wasn't right until the
last day when I was supposed to leave early and I end up,
oh,
I'm just going to be hunting for two hours and don't bring any water.
And I ended up hunting all day and going,
I don't even know how far,
18 miles maybe.
And I didn't bring any food,
any water and I'm hurting.
And I ended up shooting a deer last light.
And,
and now is to me is awesome experience.
It made the trip and made that memory,
the hardship made the memory and something that I as a hunter that non hunters
don't really maybe understand is like having these antlers around.
And when the meets long gone,
I can look at that and remember the hardship and the journey and the adventure
and these other things about the experience and the meat was a bright product.
But these are the memories that I like.
You look at that Moose and you think of something completely different than I.
Do you remember how it went down?
You remember,
you know,
maybe the struggle or carrying the meat back or whatever.
So I've may have a rack in my house that's sitting up on the mountain.
Why is that one on the mantle on that one?
Well,
that one I had to work real hard for.
So I look at it and I think it reminds me constantly of what I went through.
When you say that the experience wasn't right,
what,
what do you mean by that?
Like I feel sometimes it just wasn't a challenge.
It was I would have been shooting an animal,
not the adventure wasn't there.
The challenge wasn't there.
It just wasn't the right time.
I wanted to keep going until it,
until it happened.
I don't know.
It's a weird,
but for me hunting's about the adventure and everything behind it,
and so as well as obviously getting meat,
but there comes a point where you know,
okay,
if I didn't get a deer this week,
well maybe I'll,
I'll get one next week.
I'm not going to starve to death.
I've got a freezer with meat,
but I also want to keep that freezer full,
but so it comes to a point for me where it's about other things as well,
the experience,
the adventure,
the meat,
all combining into this.
If it's too easy,
I just don't like it that fast.
I don't know.
It'll come.
It'll happen.
You know?
For me it happened.
I started when I was younger.
I never wanted to stop hunting because I liked the experience of being out there
so much.
So I would do it.
A lot of people call trophy hunting and I'm air quoting that because it means
something different to me.
Or I would look for a bigger deer because I wanted to keep hunting and make it
more of a challenge for myself.
I find that quite remarkable that people worry about this simply because it's
not the way that people actually think about anything.
Let's remember that the longevity aspect of all of that work is a side effect.
I don't work on longevity.
I don't,
I work on [inaudible] the way you might think if you read the papers,
I just work on health.
I'm just interested in stopping people from getting sick when they get older.
Now if you think about it,
oh medicine is like that.
All medicine involves stopping people from getting sick or fixing the other.
If they I affec and all Madison had a side effect that people live longer than
they otherwise would have done.
So the only real difference between the work that sensory effect foundation dove
and the work that everything,
everyone else in medical referral is a difference of degree.
The fact that the longevity side effect of our work may be substantially greater
than the longevity side effect that we're familiar with.
It's still a side effect.
So if we come to the question,
how will I might one to live,
you know,
it's not even a meaningful question to me.
It's like saying what time would you like to go to the toilet next Sunday?
You know,
we know that that's a dumb thing to have an opinion about us.
It's a dumb thing to have an opinion about because we know we're going to have
more information on the topic nearer the time we were going to be able to act on
the information and it's the same Dell,
you know,
nobody makes decisions on the basis of how long ago they were bought.
People increasingly make decisions as they get older on the basis of how long
they think they've got to live,
but that's because the amount of time they think they've got to live is going
down,
which it won't be going down anymore.
If you've got an arbitrary amount of time behind you and other arbitrary amount
of time ahead of you,
you're deficient backing.
It's going to be based on more short term considerations.
You know,
like peer pressure and thought.
I thought I'd point out when people ask me,
they things oftentimes say,
okay,
take yourself back to the first time you got laid.
Oh yeah.
All right.
Now think about what you were thinking at the time.
What are you thinking?
Oh my God.
Oh my God,
I have to get this person into bed right now because I've only got another 60
years to live.
I mean,
it's just ridiculous.
Okay.